[Music]
from this point are the states of the
Swedes who inhabit islands out in the
ocean itself besides men and arms
possess strong fleets the build of their
vessels differs from ours in this the
stern use may like the bow so that they
can be beached either end foremost nor
are their vessels worked with sails like
ours
no yet have they their oars fixed to the
sides in regular banks but they are
fitted with loose sweeps such as may be
seen on some river craft which can be
shifted about as required from one side
to the other
among the Swedes moreover wealth and
power are held in honor and therefore
one man bears sway so now no longer do
we find any form of Independence and the
claim to obedience becomes absolute here
- there is no general right of carrying
arms as in the other parts of Germany
the weapons are locked up in the charge
of a keeper and the keeper is a slave
because the ocean acts as a rampart
against any sudden incursion of the
enemy and furthermore an idle body of
men with arms in their hand speedily
tends to mutiny it is unquestionably to
the interest of the monarch not to
commit the charge of the arms to either
a noble or a freeman nor even to a freed
man beyond the country of the Swedes
there is a another see sluggish and well
nigh motionless which is believed to be
the boundary and limit of the world
because here the last glow of the
Setting Sun shines on into the following
dawn so as to dim the brightness of the
stars nay
further we are induced to credit the
fact that the noise of the Sun rising
out of the waters is heard and that his
attendant deities are seen and his crown
of rays thus far
no further and in this report speaks
truly does nature go so now we turn back
and on the eastern shore of the Baltic
Sea we find the tribes of the east men
dwelling along the coast in their
religion and in their fashions they are
Swabians but their language is more like
the British they worship the mother of
the gods and as a religious symbol they
carry images of wild boars a symbol
serves instead of arms and every kind of
assistance and gives the devotee of the
goddess a sense of safety even in the
midst of foes iron is scarce among them
and the use of the war cup is common
they cultivate grain and also fruit
trees with more patience and is usually
exhibited by the indolent Germans and
besides this they even search the sea
for they alone among mankind to gather
Amba or blessum as they call it in the
shallows and along the shore and yet
like true barbarians they have never
asked nor ever found out what is its
nature or how is it produced long it'll
a unheeded with the other flotsam and
jetsam of the waves until the day when
our luxury made it famous
they make no use of it to themselves
they pick it up rough the shapeless lump
finds its way to us and they marvel at
the price their good for it
observation shows that it must be the
gum of a tree because within its
transparent substance they're often
visible various creatures creeping or
flying things which haven't been
entangled in the gum as it flows are
imprisoned in its mass as it afterwards
hardens therefore I venture to think
that in the isles and lands of the west
there must be groups and groves of very
luxuriant growth like those of the far
distant east dropping frankincense and
balsams and that the burning rays of
their near neighbour the sun melt and
distill these humors and
they drop into the sea below and then
the force of the storms washes them up
to the shores that lie opposite if we
test the nature of amber by applying
fire to it it blazes up like a torch and
burns with rich and strongly scented
flame and presently melts into a biscuit
mass like so much pitch or resin the
tribes of the satyr nazar counter- with
those of the sweets whom they resemble
in all respects with only one point of
difference they are ruled by a woman so
far they fall not merely below the
position of freemen but even beneath
that of slaves here Swabia comes to an
end
you
[Music]